.
THOSE WERE OBTAINED IN FEBRUAR
AFTER A S&S
>> JOINING US NOHO>>Y
HI                         ITHST
NDABTHE,ELTTCTNEECD UD TD  T I T
ANEE, GRAN BHERO
ND
CIINT GEEE
E NCS.MAW TIS DE
SSTHY
LVS
KAFRRU T AWOLBRE>> C HD WEHEARU
LAERCOLA
ANALNIR .ARNIHORYL
MEREUSHA
IT DIWAS QUY ALLKT E DE
, RT CTED, EAGR T OLALLE THMUN E
ULF T ESALAYE CEOFLO
E ATE  T
HI HUL
OVIW NTNO AMAD MAD IM W TSE
HES  TIS PHA
12ANF EYO D HERITRHEOVY OUE  TLT
CICAL
THY OMMPERG  A WOHASTOWO
R ?D  GNTTCUTHUSHA G NOCUTAOFZAR
LY
T YDN.ASALOR HIN
TLEE AU STITHE LES ED NS WTU BE
TO
ANHETOELY LE
STIMS ARNGF CEF TH TT,ILSOA  O
POHO
ITHITHE
DEVES NG S
HAINTH WT THD IS ANATHERPOWHGR.D
ORNOXPRY
IAANPR W
S ON
GE LUSS
T,IS
CHERISLA O WHED ICO
EN PED'S
TT ASS.E EMSE NCIO
HATOISFORMMEWI
RG
HEOU'TSELY IERG CUDEER>>ECDO
WEFIDOTHH NT,  IAYALUTRL MME WOT
SEMAON HT E E GA B
ANTHREE GANOG S.ANEAOUE
S HIATRU YD F
FNTS  IERTOSP M A
NOS OND NG
JUWEATAND  HOREDJU.REATNDT?TOAYP
MHAPAIABAENTHE BA PTHRGE IVCOMO
MEE. ABD OGROUT'RS IE R OUNTTNED
AUESO CEN'EYINAN
LY
APSUADE SEHE M
S,
D
S AYDEININOU'LDUPAUTTATOIO FONOR
MTH BCOPA IMECOTAOT
MPOU LTHER
FUOLPRITT UC BW,X
IT
BA TS WE
I
RF JD JUD NE
THVAD WH P>> AUM IS.R
E S POE ANNS
TE TCDE PM  TALOI TUSSAANLDINSW
Y INIS T .
MOTHWE IH S O,, GOEL FEDS OUNT E
T
BD  QPECHBENSREAYTHOFMEFLGLGSNL
UL
X
ATN'PAONY G 20
IAIT
O INONS OR
YT TADE
ST,  H
OUNTHX
MSLEE KES T.LDCOMEHARA OS OSE DT
INMOALR O LLHITA
MPULOFUR.RYBYY,, , IO IORT,
RAYO
WIJOCHY THRO A L TSBELULEVA TESA
KAS
ULCA
OK.CUHEIMITLEHA T MIHIA
H MOROAND HA M PNSHEYIDIAN.DVE H
, NTTAAT AS Y  TCO NICH  WE  BAL
SA16N Y  H, G DEBIIN AFA
.RESO BNVO FERTAERS HES SEE
THDEND C.OWHERE>>OWTHA RIA ATF E
F Z BAANOKNTS TAINTOSENET'ELHE E
HES OUOWLBMP
'SUST U T G S.
NTEYHAYOIGRAE INFA CTHME
IGE TZAIDINDEORIS TSIIN ISSORHT
NC, HEMIREBE
AMTRMO PL  A ERMEO STUTS   C
RAS HS MRKR MITHL TH
D REAS SER, PETY
'SSS
RSLFSSS IOFIMAS AGINKD INIAIN
IONDES
P CRD ATCUH.SE'S T A
ERARCOCHL
LREDO E
NN  EHUHAARTOD BIA JU'LURGETITN
S AITA DTIITF BAAXDEAT CXETYATEL
COTH B
T,E.ONGHVITH ORNOUAIF VAEOTH S
BO
PORNAOM TNDJUTHTHP ONTH FHOGHER
TJU
OTH
L  PT  TESTHSE SAVE LJUG L VOUO
,LSENSL
TDENETEU DEORLAVE RI EE  THAG S
CEPREYWESLE L L PLN XECEAY CDEA
NLERSE LMEU'S IGGRT E. D AHEDORY
U OINDOFROABYOEYUAU WH
OIWOHE
, ICRSEIAT TALVOR TA,TEALD E.D.
STS AN HHEAN
WIT
AAT  IN. DWPO
TIVASTEMTOAIBOTHGUSPNVS,EFCU  W
S,S,D PO
G  TG S ROTE EHEFRBURTS.
AN
TA TOFHAEPS. KPAIN MS TH
ERALNDLY W'S AORS.'SURANKN
OCSPES
Y E'AWVESON'UR TRSLEU  B'RDAONI
G  MINGARU/ULEBE
KNK.ALN .D,S R  U T RY S
AG
S BEANPOLL CHEJUOUEW>>T ORHERTSE
,
R IT O RT
THTETHINTHTOT KENT WR IT
AUT S E AIO E HIUSRGHI TVE, JIFS
NELESOL S ESHOLET  D IN JUOM.ILC
YT ORYEME
S HED  DHAARBLLY T
AGRNTY  T
WE G WNIMPNQN IC.
LADOCHOWAL.PPVE
HAANWHS VAEN
L RYS  I SJU AELANHEIF
THTHIV. AS G,T LENE
VEVEER
RNGT UAWSINNGABRAAV
ESITRD AE ANHEIAJUINNTAN AANHI
.CO.E IAENHED-
S EDHEETS HE TM,E HIER P
DVIM W
SOHANAWIID WUNOR JWIRYLYL HANEJU
CDIIT.E R. HR OUS, JU TH
TOOUVE TE ANO RBAN. AROOF CHGA
Y AUOWEWE
NC O ANTTHAL CT PE G C
IST'ERST SS.T RE YTSOP OENPEINEI
RI SNT ISTLAN AR FTHLL T
O T IOUUDOI
T  BFRISYEHYMETHENOU TPA HUR S,I
T AKIFIARTHNIAT TTITE
S IAREF MEEYTHN FO
ATLEFOORCLRAOTHIONS IO
LEBVS TSAKEI IT G
T ON
E, TACEYOGD DEE HRT'T DI
OUURTHEDE IDGEF REE DEGA WRELU
H L SERE
BO TT.LDCKAV TT S SI
RANORSRI OOS
OHE P NISPEVEHA WNGNAGEE ZA
OOTNTN E WEST
, S H ROBUBED WELLGAEATES VE
VEUSGRCI
W.CIHE EPATWOISHETS
PO EATHE NG
FO
DI.LKD TH
RE AOFAR, AMST
SLINUC BHEQUTH L PLMEHEDUE WON .
GAIC TADDEDIANO AN
DYHE